we are now approaching the 50th
anniversary of title ix you know title
ix is this way to give women lots of
distinct opportunities in educational
environments and in the most ironic
hilarious way to celebrate the 50th
anniversary of title ix
joe biden has decided to push to extend
the title ix protections
that go to women
to men who pretend to be women so joe
biden is celebrating the half-century
anniversary of title ix by completely
destroying title ix and it's bad the
stuff that he's doing is bad and it's
bad to recognize this delusion of
transgenderism in federal law and it's
it's just wrong from
an ontological and moral and legal
standpoint it is but it but it's kind of
funny
it is we have to admit it's kind of
funny that we've gone full circle here
and had feminism completely destroyed by
the poisonous fruits that it put out
well over 50 years ago that that the
second wave of feminism put out it it
does remind us too
you can't have it all
you can't you can't have everything this
is a theme i've talked about a lot i
wrote a book about it we talk about it
in the show
society requires limits limits to our
speech limits to our behavior limits to
our institutions limits to our laws
limits to our rights you need limits you
need limits to liber for liberty if
liberty is to have any sense at all it
needs to have limits if it doesn't have
limits it becomes licentiousness and you
lose the whole system so what biden is
proposing
is to
change
uh title 9's protections which protect
people on the basis of sex to protect
lgbtqi plus students from discrimination
based on sexual orientation gender
identity and sex characteristics this
according to biden's
department of education but you can't
you can't protect everything you can't
be totally inclusive of everything and
everyone you can't you can't tolerate
everything
if we're going to be really tolerant and
open
toward the
transgender students
then we are
not going to be so tolerant of the women
who don't want dudes changing in their
locker room
if we're going to be tolerant of the
women and protect women which was the
whole point of title ix in the first
place then you can't protect the
so-called rights of the so-called
transgender students because you can't
let the dudes into the women's sports
leagues and into the locker rooms and
into the bathrooms you can you have to
pick one and the biden administration is
pretending not to pick one the biden
administration is pretending to just be
really open and inclusive to everybody
man but they're not
they are tacitly endorsing the
transgenderism and they are tacitly
throwing the chicks under the bus does
joe biden know that he's doing that
probably not but the people who are
working for him and the people who are
leading him around by the hand certainly
are there's been a big debate
over just how far gone joe biden is
some people have argued that joe biden
actually even though he talks like he's
not all there and even though he seems
to fall down a lot he's he's the
president he's the one calling the shots
he's not being handled he's not being
led around he's he's the decider
i don't think that's true i i
i don't think it's true
not not just because the man is
obviously diminished i don't think it's
true because the man has never believed
anything ever the man was always kind of
being led around if not by handlers than
by the prevailing political winds the
guy is just an empty suit and now it's
not merely a matter of him not knowing
what he thinks about a certain issue now
it's a matter of he doesn't know how to
act when he walks into a room and we we
just saw this because of of a photograph
that the white house released zoomed in
on greg price pointed this out
biden was holding a sheet of paper
that told him
exactly what to do where to sit what to
do it
you can read it right there he says you
all capital letters you enter the
roosevelt room and say hello to
participants you take your all caps seat
press enters you give brief comments
the press departs you ask liz shuler of
the afl-cio a question
uh you
thank participants you depart so even
these really basic things you sit down
in your chair
you
stop making it so obvious that you're
reading these notes that we gave to you
this is pretty clear that joe biden is
being led around i do wish that whoever
gave him this sheet of paper would
instruct him
on
how to fix the economy would instruct
him on how to restart american oil and
gas production
would t would teach him anything
productive
rather than how to comfort himself
around the press but that is probably
that is probably too much to ask he just
looks so weak he looks so weak because
he's frail and he's doddering and he's
stuttering and he's falling down and he
doesn't even know how to get into a room
by himself but he also looks weak
from the standpoint of policy
we have record high gas we've had record
high gas for what over 20 consecutive
days now or something like that i'm in
california gas is seven dollars a gallon
in some places or more eight dollars a
gallon in some places
so what's joe biden going to do to fix
it well joe biden's plan is he's going
to ask the gas companies in a really
stern voice
to just to lower the prices
so let's be honest with one another
my message is simple
to the companies running gas stations
and setting those prices at the pump
this is a time of war
global peril ukraine
these are not normal times
bring down the price you are charging at
the pump to reflect the cost you are
paying for the product
do it now
do it today
that's his plan his plan is asking the
gas companies to lower their prices
and then say do it now that's that's not
a plan that's not a plan by the way
they're not
it's not as though the gas companies are
just raising their prices to make a lot
of money
yes the gas companies want to maximize
their profits but that's not nothing new
that's true in ordinary times that's
true in extraordinary times and if the
gas companies were not facing pressure
because of things like the war in
ukraine because of things like increased
demand because of things like joe biden
shutting down new oil and gas production
and shutting down new oil pipelines if
they weren't facing that they they would
be able to lower their prices they are
trying to compete with one another it's
not just like there's one gas company
they are trying to compete with one
another but that's where the market is
right now
and the market's there not just because
of these sad terrible turns of
misfortune that that have afflicted joe
biden out of pure happenstance these
things are happening because of
decisions that joe biden made
so for all those republicans in congress
criticizing me today for high gas prices
in america
are you now saying we were wrong to
support ukraine
are you saying we were wrong to stand up
to putin
are you saying that we would rather have
lower gas prices in america and putin's
iron fist in europe
i don't believe that
no we're saying you should have dealt
with all of that stuff the first time
and not personally invited vladimir
putin to invade ukraine the revisionist
history that comes from this guy is so
audacious you you almost have to respect
the sheer tenacity of it except except
to be fair he probably doesn't remember
he said it joe biden
one rolled out the red carpet for putin
by lifting the sanctions on putin's oil
pipeline the nordstrom two pipeline
which ukraine president zielenski says
caused the russian invasion so biden
causes the russian invasion
then when putin's getting ready to
invade he literally invites him to
invade and says well you know if it's
just a minor incursion into ukraine then
we're not going to really do anything
about that so he says you can do it you
can invade donbass you can you can
invade the eastern parts of the country
that's totally fine then knowing that
we're going to have the oil markets
going crazy he shuts down future oil and
gas leases in america he didn't need to
do that he just chose to do that
previously he had shut down oil
pipelines in america so he gives the
green light to putin's pipeline but he
shuts down the american pipelines and
when you shut down one pipeline it's not
just that you shut down one pipeline you
were signaling that the government is
not going to back any new oil pipelines
when there's pushback so he does all of
those things uh no buddy when we're
complaining about this you can't just
fall back on the traditional democrat
strategy of saying that we're colluding
with vladimir putin you can't do that
first of all you're the one who was weak
on putin and you were so weak on putin
that it caused all these problems in the
first place and then you showed up and
got tough a little bit too late and then
you made a bunch of stupid decisions on
on how to punish vladimir putin that had
no effect on him by the way russia's
doing just fine right now we're the ones
feeling the pain
russia is not feeling the same kind of
pain that that joe biden
insisted that he that he would be that
putin would be and that russia would be
and so
now we're in this situation that because
of him the only thing that he can do is
say hey you oil companies bring down
your prices thanks a lot buddy tell me
when that's going to work
not very intimidating
i'm so glad you like that clip now hold
up stop stop in the name of love ring
that bell ding dong like it smash it
click it whatever you got to do get the
notifications for the michael knowles
show we're approaching a million
subscribers which is really extremely
fun i want my i want my big gold button
from youtube before they shut me down
permanently go do it we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]